und zwar jetzt schon ein bisschen das
haus die sally dreht gerade drin und ich
bin grad am werkeln
das samstag keiner da natürlich keine
handwerker da auch keine schwarzarbeiter
sind auch keine da und wir drehen gerade
und ich zeige mir ein bisschen das haus
so mal das war so ein bisschen sehen was
wir in letzter zeit gemacht habe was
noch vor uns steht die haustür ist noch
dreckig natürlich auch ich könnte gut
auf machen schaut mal okay
hier trennte das ist eigentlich wenn
schwiegereltern und zwar haben wir da
jetzt nicht an der farbe stören die
haben nicht aus der meine frau
ausgesucht
ok und da haben wir diese holz
verbreiterungen rangemacht also diese
diese holz verbreiterung da haben wir
ganz normale ist so vielen genommen
lackiert zusammengeschnitten und es gibt
das treppenhaus oder so sieht es nachher
aus und hier sind die bretter die muss
sich nachher noch an schrauben und für
den für die treppe da haben wir an kers
boden genommen man das sieht nicht so
aus wie breiten das ding diese
normalerweise ist es nur ein parkett und
mit dem paket haben wir die treppen
verkleidet ist auch cool aus oder
und dann
und hier ist technikraum technikraum
dass integration kamera sachen equipment
hintergründe untergründe
das ist hier das sieht noch so ein
bisschen halb fertig aus aber das ist
die wand struktur des netzes zu pompey
das ist mineral putz vegan ganz wichtig
und natürlich geruchsneutral
also ein ganz ganz natürlicher baustoffe
und es nachher aus da gehen wir weiter
und zwar da gehen wir noch christine
garage und eine garage sind die die
platten schon gelegt ist so sowieso
beton optik platten richtig cool und
mitten im platten legen ob sie jagd auf
dem boden ist die platten ausgegangen
wirklich und jetzt warte ich das ja
montag wieder kommen dann gehen wir
weiter hier sind die wärme punkten
die müssen noch angeschlossen werden
momentan immer noch bei auf strom
aber ich denke nächste woche dass es so
weit ist und es ist das schaltschrank
dem 8c ließ bruder ja und der
schaltschrank smartphone technik richtig
cool von luxor
das können wir sagen ganz coole
geschichte aber es zeige oder alles noch
das sind die pläne ist ein visum elektro
plan aussieht
wahnsinn oder echte wahnsinn und das
macht alles ellis bruder seines bruder
ist meine untergang gewesen sein
dann kommen wir noch kurz her das ist
der eingang
also ist richtiger eingang von uns wir
waren erst am nebeneingang von den
eltern dann kommst du hier rein und das
ist jetzt sozusagen der eingang die
ganzen platten dass auch kohle da sie
cool aus das ist die farbe savanne
da habe ich habe ich gestern den
gestrichen den stuck gestrichen und und
sauber gemacht und habe dann die band
gekleckert aber ich musste ihn nochmal
drüber streichen die farbe bringt mir
wahrscheinlich heute abend noch der
salomon savanne
überall liegt noch bisschen werkzeug
rufen am ball hier leben wir halt hier
ist ein möbelstück das schon
eingekleidet und jetzt gehen wir in die
küche und das ist die küche von sli
sli.sff und dass er jetzt meine küche
und da sage ich mal was ganz cool ist
aber ist alles nicht fertig jetzt nicht
sagen wollte ist gefällt mir nicht es
ist ja noch nicht fertig guck mal seht
ihr das
ein bisschen wird auch hoch war
coole da
ja und hier in der küche sitzt auch noch
so aus weil noch viele teile fehlen aber
dann alle noch eingebaut was auch
richtig cool ist du kommst von der
garage kommst du einer garage im
vorratsraum und der vorratsraum es
dahinter das ist jetzt aus venedig
machst du das auf zack dann bis zum
vorratsraum siehst du in einem
vorratsraum kommst du dann in die küche
also wie bei den amis kennt ist aber ein
amerikaner das ist normal
wir kommen von den galapagos in den
vorratsraum zum vorratsraum bist du in
der küche kohlheck oder mit so einem
schrank so und jetzt willst du gar nicht
drauf kommen das ist ein schrank ist
lustig die möbel sind auch schon da zum
teil aber die müssen noch die müssen
noch aufbauen
die schränke türen eigentlich immer in
der flur ich hab meine frau ausgesucht
hat als meine frau ausgesucht ich habe
eigentlich mitzubestimmen gehabt im haus
ist nicht schlimm ich habe andere andere
fähigkeiten ja außen kommt jetzt noch
ein zaun region zaun
wir leben nicht in der wüste es war
einfach heiß in letzter zeit und ihr
seht da draußen sind raus ich darf ich
das gleich alles zeigen aber werden die
baustelle kennt weiß wie es ist du hast
viele viele ecken wo du was machst so
und jetzt gehen wir in und zwar die bank
habe ich aus suche ist hier drin
gut das macht voll viel aus du hast
jetzt zwar schon akustikdecke wirklich
bis hierhin und dann gehst du wirklich
nur einen meter rein und dann als
krasser
da war ich einfach zu geizig die akustik
aber egal nicht schlimm
hier habe ich mein roberto zusammen
freund von mir haben wir hier das toupet
gemacht das ist auch wieder das ist
vielleicht klein richtig gut aus weil da
muss man drüber
aber das ist schon im bett und technik
so richtig schön glatt
das habe ich im roberto gestern gemacht
wir sind unfertige aus aberglauben wenn
es fertig ist es der wahnsinn
und so sieht es nachher aus ganz fertig
ist so sich die wand nachher aus
momentan sieht es so aus dass
ungeschliffen und keine lasso drüber und
so sitzt aus und wenn wir noch eine
schwarze kasse darüber machen würden
wird schwarz so aussehen die wand aber
das ist dann zu dunkel natürlich der
ärger von meiner frau bei dämmerung
alles irgendwie dunkel mache deswegen
lassen was hier gesagt ist ok ganz cool
mineral putz ist hier die verteilung und
ja und dann mache ich am montag mit dem
alex zusammen machen wir diese
holzvertäfelung an die wand und wie
gesagt das wird das büro und das
gästezimmer also wir haben zwei zimmer
zusammengelegt einem ganz tollen heck
und jetzt ist es richtiges holz ist kein
problem da in dem sinne aus kunststoff
oder so und das kommt dann hier an die
wand ok dann sind wir durch
sebastian und heißes bad
sind auch die ganze fußball ist auch
richtig cool geworden das ist dass gäste
erste dusche des tc und die wand kann
man auch wieder das ist super gemacht
was ich aus
richtig grün also wir haben versucht
wirklich nur natürliche materialien zu
verwenden
es geht dann um den geruch im ganzen
haus ist alles natürlich riecht und
nicht nach kunststoffen plastik ja also
ich sehe noch extrem viel zu machen und
wir möchten nächste woche rein ziehen
wenn es möglich ist die treppe ist es
noch nicht fertig da kommt noch ein
geländer hin und glas geländer also
nicht denken dass wir die treppe so
lassen das ist einfach dass sie kaputt
geht und überall wer schon mal gebaut
hat weiß es sowas gestrichen und dann
wieder solche flecken darauf überall
das heißt am schluss geben nochmal
komplett durch machen alles sauber und
putzen alles und so sieht es noch im bad
aus ja das ist der einzige raum wo will
ich noch auf eine richtige baustelle das
alles andere ist auch seine baustelle
aber dass noch eine richtige baustelle
da wurde jetzt ein paar putts und hier
auch und hier ist es barth metro fließen
sind richtig in wartet aber ab bevor
jetzt sagt das gefällt euch nicht bis es
fertig ist
da kommt noch richtig coole boden
fließen rein da ich bin völlig außer
atem weil ich gerade treppen hoch
gelaufen bin also hier ist es hier so
schlafzimmer von uns und ihr habt da im
schlafzimmerschrank begehbarer
kleiderschrank richtig cool auch mit
coolen hacks kennt ihr das vielleicht
und zwar so das ding runter und dann
kannst du deine ding aufhängen den
händen auch ganz cool
oder hier ob sie ein spiel im schrank
sagt genau
doch die wand haben eine frau gesucht
die farbe ich weiß ob es taubenblauen
strichern daran aber egal immerhin hier
ist schlafzimmer die wand hat übrigens
keinen spaß die seele reingezogen
richtig cool ja und hier ist noch auf
ist ein boxspringbetten lustig so das
ist das kinderbad und auch wieder metro
fließen
aber wie gesagt mein akku ist der mensch
das team von samira
war es früher hell wartet gleich und was
ich sehe nichts mehr aber eine
abgeschwächte blöd
es soll
was auch gucken wir den mechanismus von
der tyrann macht die tür zu es ist und
zwar ist ein magnet drin und der zieht
an die tür zu höher magazin
na ja wohl zeigen dann hast du dir den
stuck an den wänden und wirklich alles
alles alles alles alles hier in
eigenregie den ganzen stück das ist eine
richtige arbeit begleitet also ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch mal machen wird weil
du musst dann immer die werden ja immer
so zusammen gestoßen da mussten stöße
hier zum beispiel weiß ich wiedersehe
die stöße zusammen machen und dann
musste aussprache noch mal drüber
sondern da muss ich auch nochmal drüber
eine heidenarbeit jetzt immer hier auf
den balkon und das dabei kann gehe ich
jetzt nicht mehr stimmig wasser sondern
schmiergeld kurzen einblick gehabt wie
gesagt hier geben gerade alles wie sally
ist gerade noch umdrehen und ja ich weiß
eben komisch aus jetzt aber kriegen wir
alles hin
wir möchten auch endlich rein
ok jetzt kommt nur ganz kurz dass das
nur kurz bei der rally kurz reinschauen
dann geht es runter das kommt noch ins
bad gehen wir hin
ist alles dunkel gebracht
aber gucken mal auch die melden ist
alles hoch spannend gemacht
bei uns sitzt gerade auswärts antreten
im arbeiten sind ich kann nicht
reingucken das ist das büro
wenn die jungs sich die mädels
baumschnitt ist alles aus paletten
gemacht richtig cooles macht ein freund
von uns in würzburg mit einer
behindertenwerkstatt zusammen und ganz
ganz tolle geschichte die sind so stolz
darauf hier richtig aus europaletten
gemacht cool oder die ganze aber wie
gesagt hier sieht es noch ziemlich aus
eine baustelle und das ist ganz
furchtbar in zwei wohnungen zu leben
also in unserer wohnung jetzt und dann
hier gleichzeitig auch und dann noch zu
drehen und alles da stehen sie gerade
alles klar also es war ganz ganz kurzes
update das mal kurz trübe geschaut sagt
geschaut hab das ganze natürlich
erklären wenn man so weit sind aber
momentan sind wir noch nicht so weit
okay also macht's gut
euro erhältlich mich hätte die anderen
bis dann